oh my God it's like the greatest Moon
Knight Story Ever Told God the ending of
this is amazing so this opens up with
The Moonlight on a rooftop with a bunch
of vampires bear with me because this is
dope so the way this works is he's
looking for a guy called the tutor so
what he does is he tells them the sun's
Rising but because of the nature of the
alcamax building the sun isn't directly
hitting them instead as the sun rises
and as the Earth spins it'll move around
the ALCO Max building and so he says
imagine it as a kind of Sundial every
three minutes one of you is going to die
tell me where the Tudor is now here's
the thing this switches over to task
master now this is an amazing moment in
Marvel Comics right because this guy the
tutor literally tells Taskmaster I have
a guy that I want you to kill I need you
to kill Moon Knight and Taskmaster is
like nah bro
I ain't going after Moon night man that
guy is crazy now Tudor has no idea who
he's messing with and it shows and even
Taskmaster picks it up because Tudor is
just kind of like I mean I don't really
understand like why why won't you go
after Moon night I mean you're a
mercenary you're like the greatest
fighter in the world you learn how to
fight the way other people fight as you
fight them that's your power and
literally his response is like okay so
you and your whole vampire pyramid
scheme thing the structure whatever it's
called it's a really great Racket and
you guys are really powerful and you're
really capable but Moon Knight is on a
whole different level and he says the
last people who sent me after him had
his full jacket they knew exactly what
this guy was about right United States
Marine Corps CIA freelance mercenary
work this guy in the jungle taking out
people who were otherwise impossible to
catch that's his whole thing right then
you put him in a city and then it just
becomes even more dangerous because now
it's not just a gun he has hiding among
the brush the entirety of the city is
his weapon and so the tutor responds and
says okay but like at the end of the day
this guy's just a guy right I mean me
and my people as vampires we've left our
Humanity behind a long time ago we're
exceedingly fast we're exceedingly
capable right like why would this guy be
of any concern to us and Taskmaster does
this amazing thing right he pulls out a
45 caliber bullet like a hollow point
and he says this is a 45 caliber ACP a
hollow point a flying ashtray and he
says you put one of these through a
person it comes out the other end turned
upside down and Inside Out mushroomed
torn up Twisted from the soft tissue
trauma that it's caused that's Moon
Knight he'll come at you faster than the
speed of sound go right through you and
won't care what it'll do to him and when
he comes out of the other side he'll
leave a hole in your life big enough to
drive the L train through now this is
like an amazing point makes because he
says look I mean if you wanted me to go
after Spider-Man sure you want me to
take out Daredevil yeah I'll give it a
run I mean I've even made a career out
of going after Captain America but Moon
Knight no man I'm not messing with that
guy that guy is absolutely insane and so
because Taskmaster ultimately just kind
of walks away from the whole thing Tudor
ends up turning to two characters in
order to take Moon Knight out in his
step he ends up going with nimian and
Grand malt we'll talk about them here in
a little bit because they're not overly
important but they are kind of
interesting but what Taskmaster also
does in response to this is he goes and
he finds Mark Spector after having
killed all these vampires and basically
freed the kids that they were going to
consume that's the Tudor's real gripe
here is that Mark Spector is basically
freeing the various people that they
would otherwise be feeding on and then
taking out vampires all around the city
as well as grabbing vampires that are
willing to join his cause and bringing
them to his side in this case Rhys who
unintentionally turns Soldier into
vampires if you're not overly familiar
with them it's not over important here
but the thing is that Taskmaster
approaching Moon Knight is almost kind
of a professional courtesy hey like we
fought side by side sure we don't
necessarily get along in the best way
but like at the end of the day at the
very least I feel like it's the right
thing to do so he effectively warns him
that the tutor is coming after him and
he's going to be sending some kind of a
mercenary to Target this guy now at that
point you kind of Branch away from the
main story for a second and you focus on
the three identities of Mark Spector
Steve Grant and Jake lockley now the
reason why this matters is because
during the Jed McKay run which is what
we're covering here that you didn't
really see a lot of them they were just
kind of gone one day and in reality they
just sort of vanished after the age of
khonshu what was that that was a story
that took place in Avengers where
literally Moon Knight dominated the
entirety of the Avengers team it was a
really really amazing moment but what
these personalities kind of
re-manifesting what you get here is a
bit of a fight and kind of a skirmish
between nimian Grand Mall and Mark
Spector and really they just kind of
dominate him here right I mean they take
him out quite readily but it's not
really the conflict that Jed McKay
focuses on what he focuses on is the
conversation between the three because
what these personalities are doing is
effectively kind of bickering the
reality here is Steve Grant and Jake
lockley look at Mark Spector and say yes
you're very capable there's a lot that
you can do but you can do so much more
if you had us as your personalities I
get that like you wanted to be in
control you wanted to kind of make the
decision on what your life was going to
look like but the reality here is that
when you look at Rhys who is an ally on
your side but she's a vampire she's not
trying to cure herself she's not trying
to get rid of her vampirism she accepts
the fact that that's just who she is
that's what you need to do you need to
stop rejecting Jake lockley and myself
you know kind of speaking from the
perspective of Steve Brandt and you have
to accept the fact that you are just one
third of a trio and that together we're
greater than the sum of our parts we
have have to start working together and
this kind of plea really proves to be
true when Mark Spector is taken out by
nimian and Grand Maul and so what you
get in the midst of all this is you get
Hunter's Moon and Tigra who arrive on
the scene chikra doesn't matter she's
just like a girl who was kind of spying
on him and Reporting back to the
Avengers whatever Tigris never mattered
Hunter's Moon is really interesting for
those of you guys who have not been
following our moon night coverage
Hunter's moon is basically just another
fist of konshu that for decades in
Marvel Comics we had the moon God conchu
and then Moon Knight was his avatar on
Earth and that was it with Hunter's Moon
we learned there was another fist of
konshu that had been chosen as well and
he ultimately came into conflict with
Mark Spector but he's basically every
bit as capable and every bit as powerful
as Moon Knight is and so basically
allying himself with Steve Grant and
Jake lockley allowing these
personalities to re-emerge they in turn
play their own individual roles for
example when it comes to Moon Knight in
the mid night Mission which is basically
his kind of base of operations where
people around the neighborhood will come
to him and ask for help everybody pays
in cash Steve Grant has historically
been the billionaire and while Moon
Knight has lost pretty much all of his
money Steve Grant is the means by which
they can start building all that up
specifically through money laundering
which is pretty shady but also kind of a
smart thing to do
at the same time Jake lockley that's the
cab driver personality right that's the
guy that has his ear to the ground
hearing about what's going on on the
street level and so between these three
different personalities they're able to
kind of piece together what's going on
with the tutor and what it is the tutor
was referring to when he was talking
about how he was the second most
powerful vampire in the city of New York
that there is somebody out there in the
vampire world that he fears but they're
also able to pull together information
about nimian and grand mal and what we
learn is that as a lot of you guys
should probably guessed by now if you're
familiar with Greek mythology he takes
his name from The nimian Lion of
Mythology right unbreakable skin for
Grandma she has these gauntlets on her
hand that deal these electric shocks to
anybody that she goes after which
creates what's basically a grand mal
seizure you know shorting out their
nervous system and basically killing
them but they learn pretty quickly that
they're very very capable right the
grand mal and nimian are pretty capable
they're not the most important ever but
they're still pretty pretty powerful in
their own right and so what ends up
happening is that Mark Spector ends up
traveling to Chinatown while Hunter's
moon goes directly after nimian in Grand
Maul because they both have two
different ideologies on how they should
function that Hunter's moon is more just
straight to the point attacking the foe
bringing the immediate threat to an end
mark Spector at least in more recent
years is a little more reserved right
he's a little more let's get more
information let's find out what's going
on he's very batman-esque in that way
which Moon Knight fans hate it when you
say that but it doesn't change the fact
that it's true but when they get to
Chinatown what they end up doing is
meeting with a woman named lady yulon
now the reason why she's so important
here is that in Marvel Comics when it
comes to vampires of course the most
notable vampire out there is Vlad
Dracula but he's not the oldest there
are vampires that were around long
before him and in fact there's vampires
out there that are more powerful than he
is it's just by whatever Manner and
whatever means he's effectively seized
control of like Chernobyl where really
the most dangerous vampires reside but
what we end up finding out here is that
at some point along the line lady yulon
had basically served under the direct
control of another vampire named Yi Yang
and the reality here is she was
operating as a vampire like a thousand
years before Dracula ever showed up she
is exceedingly powerful but the big
concern that Tudor has is literally Yi
Yang herself more so than that the other
part of this and the reason why Lady
yulon simply just doesn't leave
Chinatown is because they ultimately
struck a truce that lady yulon had
basically abandoned Yang and in turn
struck out on her own but abandoning
your master in the world of vampires
that's a big No-No and so while she is
able to remain underground and largely
hidden that when Tudor had basically
turned himself into a vampire by
stealing the blood of other vampires and
then consuming it a truce was struck in
the form of basically tutor saying you
let me create my own organization and
function over here and I won't tell Yang
that you're over there so it was kind of
blackmail to a degree but for the most
part it worked but what Mark Spector
does is he says between the two of them
they're both hunting for the same person
right they're both trying to take out
Tudor so while she can't act directly
what she can do is give him information
that will let him achieve his goal right
switch over to Hunter's Moon facing off
against nimian and Grand Maul this fight
is interesting and it's cool just
because for the most part Hunter's moon
is able to hold his own to a degree but
ultimately he's overpowered but it's not
really because of Grandma and nimian
it's because they call in vampire forces
from the Tudor which are basically able
to overwhelm Hunter's Moon and then in
turn the guy's neck is broken and they
simply just walk away right so like they
kill him on the spot and so following
this you basically pick up with Mark
Spector as he ultimately tracks down
Grand Maul and nimian going after both
of them and it's this really really
really dope moment because it's one of
these things like he does in more recent
years right it'll be one of these things
where like he'll ensnare somebody and
he'll be like welcome to the Midnight
Mission right like worship with me or
something along those lines like it's
just like this this really cool moment
and so they kind of taunt him right and
they tell him like you know we killed
your Sidekick we'll kill you too and his
response is like you'll try right you'll
try your best but the reality here is we
did our research on you we know exactly
what you are like we treated you like
super villains before the reality is
that you're just hired Killers sure you
have powers but you have no real basis
behind what you do outside of a desire
to make money so all we really have to
do is find a way to demoralize you and
so drawing on the power of conchu he
pulls them in to the Midnight Mission
which is sort of a term with a double
meaning the Midnight Mission is one part
the base of operations but it's almost a
kind of ethereal realm to a degree and
for the most part it shows these people
in a lot of ways their darkest Horrors
and their greatest fears right putting
nimian in a position where he's like
basically buried alive forcing Grand
Maul to experience like all the death
and destruction from the place that she
came from like forcing her to kind of
relive her past to a degree and so when
they emerge within the Midnight Mission
in this kind of ethereal realm the
response of midnight is be welcome be
welcome supplicants and it's like so
horrifying to these guys right like
they're so far out of their element
they've never experienced anything like
this before and that's the other half of
them not being super villains if you're
Doctor Octopus from the Spider-Man
Mythos you've seen all kinds of stuff
you've seen what Doctor Doom is capable
of you've seen what Spider-Man is
capable of Magneto and all these
different characters but when you're
just like some Hired Guns out there in
the world and your big task is to like
take out some dictator you're basically
small time and they've never experienced
anything like this and so ultimately
nimian says like we'll give you whatever
it was that we were paid and you'll
never see either of us again again and
his response is that's not my decision
to make and it's like one of the most
amazing moments in the story right he
says that's not my decision to make you
killed Hunter's Moon I said I did my
research you didn't do yours Hunter's
moon is not my sidekick he's my brother
he's a fist of konshu and fists of
konshu don't die and they don't they
always like come back right like they
end up coming back it's just kind of
like the benefit but also the curse at
the same time now the other thing here
is that while these folks are basically
taken out quite readily that part of the
information or at least really the big
brunt of the information given to Moon
Knight by lady yulon was that there's a
kind of big coming together of vampire
groups from across the world they're all
being brought together by Tudor and his
hope is to basically unify all these
different vampire groups and then lead
them against the forces of Dracula and
basically try to use serp control of the
entirety of the vampire world and then
form a singular Vampire Nation that
would basically be under himself now in
the midst of all of this he kind of goes
on this big you know sort of tirade
talking about like the days of the past
and superheroes and super villains and
yada yada and great big huge conflicts
and that's old hat right like under us
there will only be a world of vampires
and a world of cattle and that'll
basically be it enter nimian in Grandma
being thrown through a skylight and
landing on the floor
and then literally Moon Knight just
shows up and it's like this is a party
right so let's party and so in that
moment you have Tudor who just kind of
dismisses this whole situation so like
this is what I was talking about guys
like this is what I was referring to
right this guy Moon Knight and the
things he represents this is all old hat
stuff right this guy's ancient history I
vote that we kill this guy now as a
semblance of our new Union and the new
direction that things are going to be
going in now here's the kicker of all of
this right Reese and Soldier two people
who are vampires but are allies of Moon
Knight what they're doing is they've
actually snuck into the building and
they're tapping into the water systems
right security systems the whole nine
yards and what they're doing is hacking
the sprinkler system and so there Comes
This Moment where Moon Knight is like
okay so like you made a good speech now
it's time for mine right and he says
you've all come here under the
impression that New York is safe for you
that it represents territory to be
profited from and he says I'm sorry that
you came so far and labored for so long
under that misapprehension because this
is my city and I will Brook no
trespassers from blood Drinkers and
again it's kind of dismissed it's like
okay so like that was a really
interesting and amazing speech but like
my patience is running out right and so
then turn moonlight's like I mean you
guys don't want to see what my secret
weapon is like my whole thing like I got
a secret weapon I got a secret weapon
coming guys it's gonna be a great big
huge thing you know and so it's like
okay everybody have patience everybody
relax and then he's like Soldier Now's
the Time he pops an umbrella and Soldier
fires up the water and when that happens
it's just the sprinklers raining on
everybody I know it looks dumb it's so
dope because what Tudor does and he's
like this is it this was your plan to
make it sprinkle like to turn on the
sprinkler systems and to make us without
your grand plan hey guys I'm Moon Knight
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
go to the giant meeting of the vampires
and we're gonna turn on the sprinklers
and they will get rain on them like is
that your real big huge thing and he's
like some superhero you are no wonder
Taskmaster didn't want to go after you
you're completely and totally
incompetent and the response of Moon
Knight is you're not listening I'm not a
superhero I'm a priest and I consecrate
this water to the service of konshu that
old miserable bastard he turns it into
holy water right because remember in
order for water to become holy water it
just has to be blessed by a god it
doesn't have to be any one particular
God just a god everyone burst into
flights
it's amazing it's like one of the most
amazing things that I've ever seen with
Moon Knight right like like all these
vampires just burst into flames and
that's seemingly the end of them those
individuals who aren't immediately
killed by the holy water ultimately are
taken out by like Hunter's Moon who
re-emerges with a silver dagger designed
to kill vampires and then that same
silver dagger is given to mark Factor
who ultimately gets down to the Tudor
and where Tudor tries to bargain and
tries to reason what he does is he kills
him on the spot and then in turn they
find one person here who's a human and
is actually a spy working in the service
of Dracula and the response of Moon
Knight like what he says is you're going
to take a message back to Dracula and
you're going to tell him what happens
when you make a move in the city of New
York this is my city no one's allowed in
this city if he brings his vampires here
they won't just be met by me they'll be
met by me my forces the midnight sons
and Blade with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end if
you guys want to get caught up on
everything related to Moon Knight
including the age of konshu when he just
absolutely buckled The Avengers make
sure you guys check out this playlist
and I will catch you all later peace